wir schauen in die usa eine neue welt
der gewalt eine neue welle der gewalt
eine welt auch dutzende tote in den
letzten wochen nach immer neuen
schießereien aber sind nicht nur
amokläufer auch die alltägliche gewalt
nimmt dramatisch zu auch in new york der
stadt die niemals schläft aber auch der
stadt in der kein tag ohne verbrechen
vergeht
warten auf die u-bahn und dann das ein
mann greift zu und schleudert eine frau
auf die gleise einfach so aus heiterem
himmel und am helllichten tag es ist das
jüngste brutalo video aus new york city
ein fahndungs-video der polizei
veröffentlicht vor wenigen stunden
erst anfang april
29 verletzte bei einer schießerei mitten
in der rush hour new yorks u bahn wird
immer gefährlicher attacken mit hermann
attacken mit messern und prügeleien sind
an der tagesordnung die u-bahn ist das
verkehrs rückgrat der 8,5 millionen
einwohner metropole
aber wer will hier noch fahren es gibt
angriffe gegen homosexuelle attacken
gegen menschen mit migrationshintergrund
oder angriffe wie hier mit einem beutel
voller fäkalien einfach so ohne auslöser
doch wie kommt es zu dieser
gewalteskalation ex-polizist und
professor für strafrecht josef ackerl
ohne hat eine antwort
es gibt bei der polizei direktiven bei
der strafverfolgung nicht mehr so hart
durchzugreifen
es gibt die idee dass täter ihre strafe
ja nicht mehr in harten knästen wie
rikers island absitzen müssen dass es
teil des problems früher waren leute
eingeschüchtert wenn sie was schlimmes
täten würden sie in rikers island landen
diese angst gibt es nicht mehr jeder
politiker verspricht er würde das einen
dicht machen wir haben da noch nie so
wenig insassen viren
die verbrechens welle in new york nicht
ab nicht nur im untergrund auch draußen
auf der straße über 48.000 verbrechen
wurden in den ersten fünf monaten des
jahres gemeldet ein zuwachs von 38 42
prozent im vergleich zum vorjahr und
viel zu häufig greifen sich die täter
ihre opfer willkürlich aus der menge wie
die 16 jährige der in risen der beim
betreten eines musikladens ein messer in
den rücken gerammt wird sie erleidet nur
eine leichte stichwunde ihre mutter ist
dennoch fassungslos
ein polizist zeigte uns das video wir
sind vor schock fast an die decke
gegangen es passierte so schnell sie
sagen das video und dachte mein gott das
war so willkürlich wie kann eine junge
person morgens aufwachen und entscheiden
ich gehe jetzt zu irgendjemanden und
steche ihm oder ihr in den rücken was
ist denn der sinn des ganzen sie ist es
16 sie ist jung wir gehen tagtäglich an
leuten vorbei man erwartet doch nicht
dass sich da einer umdreht und die ihr
ein messer in den rücken jagt
massive gewalt es ist wie die rückkehr
in die finstersten zeiten des big apple
die 80er und 90er damals litt new york
unter billigen drogen wohnende
arbeitslosigkeit und einer massiven
haushaltskrise seit januar steht eric
adams an der spitze seiner metropole der
war früher selbst polizist aber die
gewalt in seiner eigenen stadt scheint
er nicht im griff zu haben
und wir schalten direkt nach new york zu
unserem reporter herbert bauernebel der
dort im times am time square in der u
bahn station ist in einer u-bahn er will
ich kann es nicht genau sehen traut man
sich überhaupt noch in u bahn dieser
tage wir haben getraut sich in die oper
natürlich aber man hat ein mulmiges
gefühl dabei man sieht auch menschen die
einfach weit weg vom bahnsteig stehen
natürlich nach dieser serie an vorfällen
beim menschen auf die gleise geschubst
wurde man spürt schon eine
angespanntheit eine gewisse angst man
versucht einfach hier so vorsichtig wie
möglich zu sein und man blickt sich auch
gegenseitig über die schulter aber klar
ist natürlich das ist das wichtigste
verkehrssystem dieser achteinhalb
millionen metropole und es ist auch
besonders wichtig jetzt bei dieser phase
wo man versuchen möchte menschen
arbeiter zurück in die büros zu bekommen
hier in new york einfach diesen schwenk
machen davon hatten vom home-office zum
richtigen office zum richtigen büro nach
dem abklingen der carola pandemie und
das ist besonders schwierig war die
menschen die vielen pendler die
außerhalb von new york leben immer noch
angst haben hier dieses verkehrsmittel
zu benutzen
aber etwas ist passiert seit anfang der
90er ende der achtziger dem höhepunkt
der gewalt will in new york das ist
jetzt wieder so dramatisch wie schlimm
ist es tatsächlich nur die fehlen der
abschreckung wie wir in dem bericht
gerade gehört haben
es gibt verschiedene faktoren wie gesagt
macht er nach dem höhepunkte gewaltwelle
anfang der 90er gab es einen
kontinuierlichen abstieg beim verbrechen
besonders bei morton bis auf einem
ortsteil von ungefähr 300 das alles hat
sich geändert im jahr 2020 und da gibt
es mehrere faktoren einer natürlich war
der tod des afrikaners george wright der
zu unruhen hier in new york und den rest
amerikas geführt wurde gewalt extrem
gestiegen ist der zweite fehler der
passiert ist der damalige bürgermeister
bilde blase hatte praktisch sein eigenes
police department nicht unterstützt die
npd und die das hat natürlich auf die
moral gedrückt viele polizisten sahen
einfach keinen grund mehr hier
einzuschreiten und auch viele der
polizisten sind in pension gegangen das
heißt wir haben hier ein kleineres
police department es gibt auch probleme
beim rekrutieren neuer police officers
und das ganze geht hab natürlich mit
einer art philosophie von einiges
staatsanwältin hier die einen weichen
strafvollzug verfolgen all das war
praktisch ein rezept für ein desaster
jetzt sieht man eben die gewalttaten
steigen man sieht sie teilweise außer
kontrolle und es ist ein wirklicher
schleier der angst wer sich hier über
die metropole gelegt haben ist kurz noch
der neue bürgermeister eric adams ist ja
ehemaliger polizist kann er das ganze
drehen
man muss fairerweise ein bisschen mehr
zeit geben dann natürlich so solche
fehlentwicklungen umzukehren in wenigen
wochen ist nicht nicht leicht aber
bisher gibt es auch an ihm kritik denn
bisher also sagen ebenfalls einige hätte
es mehr worte als karten gegeben und die
taten die er gesetzt wer eher symbolisch
die bisschen allerdings er hat eine sehr
effektive polizeieinheiten endlich suite
pro unit wieder ins leben gerufen und
versucht jetzt zumindest was von der
straße zu bekommen herbert bauernebel
aus new york vielen dank herr
berlin